back off from the UFO subject for the
same reason UF if you think about the
possibilities like truly truly truly
think about them it can put you into
some dark dark places that it seems
inescapable I do think that there's
something like God is always with you
and I say this as someone who's like I'm
not even a believer I'm like someone
who's entertains believing or hopes to
believe but also hopes to not believe
like if I pray like it's praying for
Faith but also not Faith like I'm afraid
of God I'm extremely afraid of what it
means that God exists I'm extremely
afraid of what it means that God doesn't
exist I'm like I'm fearful at both ends